[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout hope
everyone's having a great week
if we haven't met yet I'm Rachel Dempsey
I lead our Pro Community here at posit
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to hear what's going
on in the world of data across many
different Industries
and we're here the same time same place
every Thursday so if you are watching
this as a recording sometime in the
future there'll be a link where you can
add it to your calendar below as well
together we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment for
everybody
and so we love to hear from everybody no
matter your level of experience or area
of work or industry
I like to say that it is totally okay to
just listen in though if you want but
there's also three ways you can jump in
and ask questions or provide your own
perspective so you can raise your hand
here on zoom and I'll be on the lookout
here
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and if you're maybe in a coffee shop or
your dogs barking or something just put
a little star next to your question in
the zoom chat and I can read it instead
otherwise I'll just call on you to jump
in and add some context
and then lastly we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously and I see Hannah just shared
that in the chat here
but thank you so much Matt for joining
us here today as our featured leader Max
Frazier is former Chief analytics and
underwriting officer currently a
strategic advisor at Pi insurance and uh
Matt I'd love to have you maybe kick us
off by introducing yourself and sharing
a little bit about your role and
something you like to do outside of work
too sure
uh so I'm Matt Frazier
um I actually started in data science in
2008 uh right after the financial crisis
prior to that I was more of an insurance
guy I actually have a background in in
philosophy
um specifically metaphysics and so um
I'm sort of a Carl paparian at heart if
anybody knows who Carl popper is who is
the first empirical skeptic and so
um I sort of uh transitioned my uh
empirical skepticism over into data
science and started to learn it in 2008
before that uh I carried a number of
executive positions at different
insurance companies in the underwriting
space at that point in time right from
let's say 1998 through 2008.
um
I did not know of an insurance company
that was actually doing any predictive
modeling at all and it is still the case
uh that really the national carriers are
using AI they're using data science
they're using predictive modeling but
most of the smaller mutuals right the
ones that are only in a couple of states
are really using other predictive
modeling software ads and service
companies to do all of their predictive
modeling so
um data science was a a sort of an
obvious transition after I made it but I
had no idea what the heck it was before
I got into it I was just a philosophy
guy I was a language guy I love language
and I love understanding what is
knowable and what isn't knowable right
but I didn't really realize that you
could translate that into mathematics
until I got into a company called Valen
Technologies
um so I sort of got out of the insurance
industry and went into a company that
was adjacent to the insurance industry
actually selling to uh insurance
companies uh predictive analytic and and
data science Solutions right but before
that I was I was pretty good on the
Actuarial side I'm not a classically
trained actuary at heart but I was the
director of pricing at a number of
different insurance companies
um as I sort of progressed through my
career uh and and so I got pretty good
at using Excel okay I get pretty good at
grinding through data I get pretty good
at philosophically understanding data
and understanding
um you know what it what it meant if
certain data had low integrity versus
high integrity and things like this was
really good at data wrangling but I
didn't have any idea what a glm was and
don't ask me to write any formulas down
because you know I I let you guys I let
the data scientists do that right
um but I'm pretty good at picking models
apart because of my empirical skepticism
that I learned at a very early
um sort of age through college and high
school my dad was a physician he always
used to kind of hammer me on hey are you
sure you know that do you know that or
do you think you know that do you
believe you know that because beliefs
can be wrong
um and so when I was at Valen I was able
to get trained by a former Chief
modeling officer at Capital One valon
Technologies uh one of the major
investors uh was Nigel Morris who is one
of the co-founders of Capital One and
Capital One was sort of one of the first
banks that got into
um machine learning got into predictive
modeling uh on the credit card side and
so they had a very robust understanding
they were one of the early adopters
let's say in the banking space in the
fintech space of actually using
predictive models in order to create a
competitive Advantage uh or an Arbitrage
opportunity within the credit card space
and so we were able to really capitalize
on uh that connection with Capital One
we were able to take some really smart
people from Capital One bring them into
Valen and I really learned on the job
um from one of the former uh Chief
modeling officers on the commercial Auto
and auto finance side from Capital One
one uh and I the second I get into I
absolutely loved it I mean van was my
favorite job the second I got into data
science I was like oh God this is what
I've been missing my whole life right
like I love the language but to be able
to blend the language and the math
together the language and the data
together and actually produce something
that gives another you know company a
moat or a competitive advantage in a
Marketplace man that's really cool like
I can actually take things from the
philosophy side where all you're really
doing is you know creating more
questions for yourself and actually
Translating that into real durable value
in the world like something that's
tangible that can be seen through
dollars and cents was super duper
excited you know I I got really excited
about that and then I translated that
into
um Pi insurance I was one of the what I
would call the silent co-founder
um at Pi we took all of the learnings
that we uh were able to extract from
Valen Technologies working with about 56
different insurance companies in the
Property and Casualty space and we
translated that into building durable
models that created a competitive
advantage and an Arbitrage opportunity
for pi Insurance pie started in oh gosh
I want to say it was 2018 now so
um we're now writing about 300 million
uh we're on the path to about 350 maybe
400 million this year and I believe
where the fastest growing
um and quickest most uh most capitalized
uh in in suretech that has ever existed
so somehow I was able to take that
Philosophy degree translated into data
science create a competitive advantage
and uh raise a whole bunch of money and
create a company that now employs
unfortunately we just went through what
what we call a reduction Force but we
had about 460 employees we now have
about 400 employees now and I think
that's the end of the The Cutting so far
but
um I've been very pleased with what I've
been able to do and what I've been able
to learn in data science and I'm just
looking forward to a lot more learning
opportunities as we move forward
no you asked what do I like to do
um yeah
skiing fly fishing hiking I like to be
outside
um so as long as it's outside and it's
sort of a more of a single sport I
really like that kind of a thing I'm not
a big team sports guy that's not not
that I'm not big on teams because I'm
huge on teams I just don't play a lot of
team sports I play tennis and things
like that that are more double or single
kind of thing
well where are you outside right now in
your background you're uh virtual
background this is um Wadi Rum so so
this is right near Petra in Jordan
and I I try to keep it you know fresh
with all my backgrounds so I have goofy
backgrounds like Animal House and
Casablanca and other things like that
this one just happened to be up on my
zoom today
well thank you so much for joining us
today Matt I I feel like I can feel the
energy from you and excitement coming
through the computer so thank you for
bringing the energy here today
um something I
really wanted to ask you about initially
because it was something that comes up
quite a bit in the data science Hangouts
so I know you wrote your bio for the
hangout with chat gbt so I feel like
this is a good place to to start off but
I'd love to hear your thoughts on chat
chat ubt but also at AI in general and
how you think it may impact the
insurance industry
okay
um I'll start with in general and then
we'll go into Insurance
um you know
there's a lot of people on both sides of
one particular argument and that is
whether you know chat GPT has the latest
sort of tangible instantiation of AI
right is AI going to take over the world
are we going to limit it in a Terminator
Universe where AI eventually is
significantly smarter than us and
somehow grows in tension
um I'm in the camp that I think that
artificial intelligence and large
language models and the like
um are going to be a benefit to society
they are not going to be a tractor to
society now do we have to be careful of
course right human beings are never at a
space morally where we are
technologically and so um the technology
is going to force us uh to reevaluate or
transvaluate our scale of values right
we're going to have to understand what
can be done and we're going to have to
understand how we can make sure that we
are Distributing things like AI in some
Equitable Manner and you know in
Insurance
um this is a real big problem especially
in the industry that I'm in uh we have a
lot of small carriers out there but they
don't have any of the data there are
about five or six or seven very large
carriers uh that beat
all of the small carriers up with data
okay now we're not talking about large
language models we're literally just
talking about simple glms we're talking
about any of the normal machine learning
algorithms whether it be gradient
boosting whether they be random Forest
uh whether they be you know other
um elastic Nets or you know tree models
it doesn't really matter Whoever has the
most data wins usually in insurance
right into insurance is a little bit
weird
um we have a zero point inflation on all
of the distributions that we're looking
at so in most cases when you look at
insurance policy about 75 to 97 percent
of the time the right answer is zero
right people just don't have losses but
when they have losses some of them can
be very significant and they can really
hurt businesses they can hurt
individuals and that's what insurance is
for right insurance is for that highly
unlikely event that it that is
catastrophic right that that's where
Insurance really helps society and at
the end of the day and that's a really
interesting problem to solve for a lot
of data scientists right the issue is
that most of the carriers that are out
there that aren't the big National guys
don't have enough data in order to do
that right and that's a big problem
because you can you know you can use
that your advantage to become a monopoly
and if you see Hartford if you see
Travelers if you see Liberty Mutual if
you see Swiss three or some of the large
reinsurers they have all the data
so they can almost always build better
models because at this point the
algorithm doesn't matter as much as how
much data you have and the Integrity of
that data right it's really important to
understand your problem space and to
think very deeply about that problem
space and where you can go get data in
order to solve that problem space and so
at Valen analytics when I was there we
actually created a Consortium data set
and that was specifically for small
carriers it was to allow small carriers
and new entrants to the insurance Market
to be able to take advantage of large
data sets with people who had subject
matter expertise and data science
expertise to be able to deploy models
for those small carriers and democratize
the insurance base to really allow new
entrance and Innovation into that space
if anybody knows anything about the
insurance space now the one thing that
is very very clear is that it is
probably one of the slowest moving
Industries on the planet and the reason
that it's one of the slowest moving
Industries on the planet is because
there are five carriers that hold all
the data and they don't have to move
they already have a durable advantage
over everybody else and so they're not
really interested in innovating now
that's changed in the last decade quite
a bit because of people like Valen and
other software as service companies that
are coming out or data scientists and
service companies that are building
Consortium data sets or finding novel
ways to use public Source data in order
to create large either empirical or
synthetic data sets that can bring value
to bear for some of these smaller
carriers and allow new entrants into the
industry and what I think that's going
to do is it first of all it's going to
disrupt the industry that's that's why
the insurance industry has coined a new
term called insured Tech right
um most of those insure tech companies
are not just Tech they should call it
like insured data or ensure machine
learning or ensure AI because that's
really what all of the insurer techs are
doing they're using AI they're using
machine learning it's really not AI it's
machine learning right
um it's building models on large
um Consortium or synthetic data sets uh
in order to extract or provide that
value to smaller carriers so they can
compete with the big guys because most
of the small guys either just sort of
you know lager along you know like they
barely Soldier on through the snow in
Siberia right or or they just get
subsumed or bought required by some of
the large guys and so they just get
bigger and they continue their Monopoly
what I'm really interested in is making
sure that you know data science and
large available data sets can actually
democratize the industry that I'm in
because I believe it's an unfair
industry and I believe it's a
quasi-cabal of uh monopolis that
actually controlling this industry and
that is true in many many Industries and
I think there's going to be a huge
opportunity especially with the Advent
of chat GPT and these llms for software
as disturbance companies to go out and
very easily get customers in order to
optimize those standardized llms and do
other data science and machine learning
projects for these companies deploy
those models for them and allow them to
hit those models with with apis and
bring that value to Bear now there's a
lot more insurance companies that are
looking to create data science practices
inside of their own carriers the biggest
issue is you have to get a critical mass
of data in order to do that I mean Pi is
running 350 million dollars in premium a
year and we don't have enough data we
actually had to go to Valen to purchase
additional Consortium data in order to
build a robust model right because of
that Zero Point Mass so you have to be
not just a slightly big insurance
company you have to be about a six seven
hundred million dollar insurance company
that's been writing for three to five
years at that level in order to have
enough data to build a really robust
model and so that's where I think using
Consortium data sets or novel data sets
or or even some of these new algorithms
like um like adversarial algorithms to
create synthetic data sets that are very
closely mirrored to the underlying
empirical data to be able to bootstrap
and expand that data to be able to make
more robust models there's a lot of
companies that I've talked to that are
coming out with things like that and Pi
is actively doing a lot of pocs with
those types of companies to find out
whether we can take our smaller data set
and we can exponentiate that data set so
we have a much larger data set to be
able to build models on
really interesting thank you I see Liz
had a question a follow-up question in
the the chat Liz do you want to jump in
here
sure
um so I I worked in uh the casualty
space as a analyst for five years I'm
actually
about to have an interview next week
with uh for a junior data scientist role
trying to get back in the space
um
but uh I was curious regarding chat GPT
um I think you know there's a lot of
people doing like para programming and
stuff with that and they maybe don't
realize that when they submit a question
or a prompt to chat gbt if it's not a
locally hosted llm that the host is
owning that data whether they're allowed
to or not and that creates a huge
exposure I'm curious if you have any
thoughts or comments about that
liability and that exposure yeah that's
actually a massive liability and I don't
think that the insurance space is going
to
um
is going to capitalize on chat GPT
especially in the pricing and
underwriting domain until uh there is
assurances that the data that they put
in to train specific instances of the
llm are going to be protected in some
way and cordoned off uh from the larger
language model so
um right now I know that there are
several companies that I'm working with
are like well we we don't want to do
anything until we have absolute
assurance that our data is safe and that
no one else can
gain any advantage through the use of us
putting that data into
right some can some container or some
space that allows us to train those llms
and I think that is where a lot of
um new companies are going to be
extremely successful is going to be you
know prompt engineering and
specialization of those larger language
models um sort of the base model and
making sure that they're doing that in
such a way that they can make sure that
they have an understanding of the
custody of the data and that they can
they can either tokenize that data or
make sure that that data doesn't get
into sort of the larger pool of data
that's being used in order to optimize
the underlying base llm it's it's really
important I think until that happens
Chad GPT is going to be used more for
um in insurance it's going to be used
for automating processes around changing
policies right making sure that the
language uh and the chat functionality
goes back and forth very smoothly
without any human intervention but I
don't think that you know it's really
gonna the insurance industry is really
going to capitalize on chat GPT as an
underwriting agent right until all of
that data can you know is safe and is
completely separated and mutually
exclusive from the larger pool of data
that's going to be a really important
piece of the puzzle that some of these
softwares or service companies are gonna
have to figure out
I mean I know that I I've already told
my team at Pi uh and uh I worked with
several other carriers and I've told
them all don't don't put your data into
chat GPT right now because then
everybody gets to use it right like this
this thing learns and uh it's like uh
you know it's also about like work
product and stuff you know uh totally
they if you if you say oh hey I need
help fixing this uh you know chain
ladder model or whatever but you have a
little bit of Secret Sauce in there and
then someone else asks and then boom
your secrets out and you lose an edge
that's exactly right I mean even in in
in our business we have a very
specialized transformation of the target
space that we use for our line of
business workers compensation and we
don't want anybody to know that that
that's a specialized transformation I
haven't seen anybody else in the
industry use it works really really well
I don't want to give that information to
anybody right
um and the second I pop it in there it's
possible for someone to extract that
unless new technology uh and uh updated
knowledge is actually given to the
insurance industry by some of you know a
new company a new individual uh that's
working with these companies that
actually understands how to specialize
these llms without delivering the data
to the larger Baseline model
I personally don't know how to do that
yet but that I I know that that's
something that's being talked about very
actively and heavily within the
insurance space it's well how do we take
advantage of this and if we're going to
take advantage of this how do we not
give away our secret sauce
and take advantage of it at the same
time well like from my perspective it
seems like the best use would be like
having a a privately hosted uh llm that
serves as like a communication agent for
people filing claims or whatever and
their apps you know where it's kind of
low stakes you can segment the data make
sure it doesn't get out but you also
have like clear knowledgeable
communication happening that's automated
and understandable and the the higher
end stuff like you know maybe maybe
we'll get there but that's like pretty
not there right now I think that's
exactly right the the other big piece of
the puzzle that is going to be there is
right now almost all insurance companies
are
um
all insurance companies they're using
machine learning are using it in order
to straight through process some
accounts but there's always a human
being overlay right so you allow the
model to make about 30 to 50 of your
decision than the other fifty percent of
the decisions 50 to let's say 30 of the
incision are sent to an individual
underwriter in the world in order to
make a human decision right with the
Advent of llms a lot of that need to
have a human individual in the mix goes
away right or gets pushed back in the
funnel so you can allow a machine
learning model right which is which is
highly uh calibrated and constrained
right and then you here's the trick you
get to blend that together with an llm
that is highly specified and constrained
and optimized so that those two pieces
of the puzzle work together right and
then you can remove the underwriter and
use them after the decision is made as
check right so you've got a human in the
loop who is essentially making sure that
the decision you know didn't have any
gaps in it right or a human that can
identify the gaps that exist in the
system so that you can improve the
system eventually what you get to is
that maybe you've got a human that needs
to be involved you know five percent of
the time instead of a human that needs
to be involved fifty percent of the time
and the decisions are more consistent
and create more separation between the
good risk and the bad risk
right now the other big piece of that
puzzle is is equitability so you know
are you treating everyone the same
across the parameters that matter right
whether it's demographic whether it's
race whether it's something else you've
got to make sure that you've got a human
in there that is making sure that the AI
the llm and
um you know the uh glm or the machine
learning models uh are actually not
um introducing some specific bias into
the overall solution that was actually
one of the anonymous slido questions was
how do you ensure that bias is not
introduced when generating synthetic
data so
it's it's an awesome question and it
depends on what you mean by bias right
because there's bias whether it's
statistical bias or some other bias
inherent in every single model that's
built right what we try and do uh is we
we look very closely at the variables
that are going into all of our models
and that's what's really hard to do with
an llm I mean you know somebody else
almost has to make sure that there's no
bias in the in the Baseline llm
um but it's all about the covariance so
when we're building a machine learning
model we're taking a look at the
covariates and we're making sure that
those covariates are highly empirical
and that they're based on you know
Insurance data uh for for the most part
now there's a lot of demographic data
that can come in especially in the line
of business that I'm in which is workers
compensation
um if anybody doesn't know what workers
compensation is it's essentially a
coverage that uh employers buy so that
their employees are covered uh if they
have an accident and it pays for all of
the medical bills plus
um their their weekly wage as long as
they cannot get back to work at the same
world right
um and when when you think about that
there's a lot of demographics that come
in things like average household size
are actually important oddly average
hail size is important and you can't
imagine what kind of biases that
actually introduces so if you're a
homeowner's insurer average hail size
really matters right like the people in
Colorado right they have higher premiums
than the people in um North Dakota
because North Dakota has less hail than
Colorado does right Washington has less
hail than Colorado does of course
Washington has different problems right
they have floods and things like that
California uh is highly biased because
of other things but what what you really
care about is okay is there some
um group of people
um that already have it tough and are we
making it more tough because of
something that's inherent in a covariate
that we're using uh that just makes it
more difficult for those people to
purchase Workers Compensation Insurance
we try as best as we can to remove those
variables whether it's average wage
average household any race demographics
anything like that is completely just
dumped out of our data set right at the
beginning even though those exist
right
um
and so we do our best to try and
minimize those biases but again there's
always going to be inherent and
potentially unknown or unknowable biases
that actually exist within an overall
um algorithm estimation so
um we do the best that we can nobody's
perfect at this
um there's a lot of new companies that
are coming out with novel data like
behavioral data and that's something
that the industry is talking about very
very closely right it's like hey if we
can capture what your media content
consumption is
right and that has a significant risk
separation between the good risk and the
bad risk
um you know is it highly correlated with
things like race is it highly correlated
with other things because it may be the
case that people of you know different
backgrounds
um consume different media and that may
inherently have some sort of correlation
to to things that kind of matter with
regard to uh you know the the current
Zeitgeist in terms of uh which groups
are
um you know having trouble and which
groups aren't right
um and so there's a lot of conversation
there
definitely I I see a lot of great
questions coming into the chat so I want
to make sure I I get to some of these
too I'll be more concise no no no these
are good it's a great discussion I just
want to make sure I I get some of these
too but uh but and if I I see you had
asked the question a bit earlier in the
the chat do you want to jump in here
I think you largely answered it in that
but I was just really interested when I
went shopping for life insurance
recently that uh there were some
companies that were not the biggest
companies that were were able to do
everything instantly online and didn't
require things like blood draws or
physicals or any of that kind of like
physical evidence and I'm I was assuming
that that was because they are using
their models or is it just because they
are big enough that they can kind of
like marginalize and don't need to be
that specific I'm just curious what sets
up one company to be able to do that in
one not to be able to do that there's
there's a lot of moving pieces there so
generally speaking what I would say is
those people who are doing it online
their overall rate level is a little bit
higher right because they don't have all
of the data that some of the larger
people who are not doing it online
actually have and so let's hear an
extremely healthy individual okay you
have no medical biomarkers you have gone
to some company and gotten a very
extensive blood draw done and you have a
really good understanding of how healthy
you are right you're very likely going
to get a better rate with a large
company who's not online than a smaller
company who's online having said that
smaller companies are using more novel
data than the older companies are in
order to be able to allow consumers to
purchase those types of products online
and the rate level isn't that different
right you are going to get a discount if
you get your blood drawn and do the
whole thing if you have extremely good
biomarkers right but if you don't have
extremely good biomarker it's probably
the best choice for you to go online and
just get the policy because they're
going to look at completely different
stuff now you have to understand that a
lot of those life insurance companies
are also you know grabbing
um a lot of that data that you know many
of us don't even know they're grabbing
right so so purchasing
um patterns uh you know media content
consumption Trends behavioral Trends
these kinds of things that they can
actually grab so they're using your
digital fingerprint a heck of a lot more
than you they're using your biomarkers
right
um and so you're going to get a higher
rate but they can still do a really good
job of separating risk finding out
whether you know you're really
interested in drinking a lot of You Know
Jack Daniels or whether you're really
interested in drinking a lot of mushroom
tea right so those are you know those
are going to be very very different and
companies now uh can use a lot of these
third-party API aggregators in order to
get all of that information and consume
that information through deep earning
models that are actually quite good at
separating good life insurance risks
from bad life insurance risk
thank you that answer your question
I see a thumbs up
um so Eric had asked a question you put
the star so I'll read it but it's the
question was love seeing the energy in
your communication do you have any tips
on how we can improve our communication
so I have been talking to large groups
of people for a very long time
um when I started
I pictured everybody in their underwear
I'm sure you've heard that it's an old
probe right
um but I think one of the most important
things to understand about people in
general is we all put our underwear on
the same way we all take a you know we
all take a number two and a number one
in exactly the same way okay
um
I very early in my career uh was was
able to to essentially come right out of
college and I got an underwriting
position at an insurance company that
was very small I was employee number
five and so I had Direct access to the
CEO since since I was right out of
college so my working environment did
not include any social hierarchy like
everything was flat and so that's what I
would encourage all of you to do is if
you're really going to speak your truth
you have to be able to punch through
um the
the The Imposter syndrome that you might
have the impression of a social
hierarchy that you might have you have
to be able to talk to a board member or
a CEO in the same way that you would
talk to a colleague because we're all
the same we're all humans
we all have the same needs and we you
know maybe some people are smarter than
others and okay that's fine right but if
you really want to do a good job of
communicating you have to communicate on
the same level as another individual
which means you have to assume that you
are on the same level as the other
individual I would just encourage
everybody to understand that we're all
human beings we all have our foibles I'm
you know there's something that's
running around on LinkedIn right right
now and and it is you have to you have
to make sure that you are
really open and that you're listening to
other human beings not just what they're
saying but how they're saying it and the
important reason for that is that in
anyone's life any other human being only
knows about one to two percent of what's
going on in their life right
um and so I would just really encourage
you to empathize and consider yourself
on exactly the same level as the people
that you're talking to and it doesn't
matter whether they're a manager a
senior manager a director a VP or a
c-level employee or even a board member
or an investor if you talk to them as if
you are on their same level and they're
on your same level you will get better
responses I promise you you'll get
better responses and I know it's easy to
say and it's a lot harder to do because
that anxiety comes up
um if that anxiety comes up picture them
in their underwear understand that they
take a crap just like the rest of us
right and they've got their own problems
they you know they I got where I got
because I was lucky I made a couple of
the right choices and I think probably
90 percent of the people that are
actually in positions like mine they got
there through dedication they got there
through making sure that they were very
consistent at a couple of things that
made sure that they were a person that
could be attracted and that they were a
person that could be counted on right so
doing those small things every single
day is gonna is gonna do wonders for you
now it's great if you come up with a you
know Svengali move and you come up with
the greatest thing that the company has
ever seen right that's sort of an added
bonus but where you win is doing small
consistent things every single day and
talking to everyone like they're a
brother or like their sister
um and making sure that you are really
empathizing with them and that they know
that you have the company's interest at
heart that you have their interest at
heart and that you're listening to what
their needs are if you can do that then
you will become much more confident in
how you speak very very quickly now I
will say I've got a lot of bomb bass too
my wife tells me again and again that
I'm the only person she's ever met that
doesn't give a crap what anybody else
says about them and that's completely
true I just don't worry about my image
that much I worry about being a good
human
I don't worry about being a pretty human
or professional human or the smartest
human on the planet I just worry about
being a good human that people can trust
and that people can count on and that's
it
what you just said about like doing
those small consistent things was
reminding me of that video I saw you
just posted on on LinkedIn about like
being an effective leader isn't just
like going to the leadership Workshop
one time a year and saying okay well I'm
trained on on being a leader
um and so
I was also wondering like what what are
other
things that you think make someone an
effective leader
um
so there's a couple of things that I
post on LinkedIn some of them are quite
old there was one that I posted that and
I'm sure everybody's seen this the
difference between a boss and a leader
right A A Boss sits behind you with with
a whip and you know he yells at you to
get stuff done and a leader is the one
who's pulling you along he's or she is
the one who is
um removing the blocks who is actually
serving the employees and I consider
myself and I'm a strong believer in
servant leadership right I'm not
anybody's boss I am the person who is
responsible for making sure that all of
the conditions are set up so that each
and every one of my employees can
succeed and can fully
um explore the domain of their
competencies
that's my job right my job is to find
smart people and then set up the
conditions and get the heck out of the
way and if there's a blocker that is in
their way I need to go find a way to
remove that blocker
right now are there performance reviews
and things like that yeah every company
has them I am a strong proponent against
them so I hate performance reviews I
think that performance reviews should be
done every single day between the
individuals that are working together
and I don't think it should be between a
boss and uh that boss of employees I
think it should be the individuals on
that their colleagues on the team that
are working together with one another
that's where that feedback should be
coming from it should be a 360 degree
feedback because performance reviews are
a thing that can be weaponized so easily
and they say more about the person who's
giving the review than they do about the
person who's being reviewed period that
is my position now I'm happy to argue
with anyone about that particular
position because of how strongly I
actually believe in that position I
think that if we can create a
egalitarian society where everyone is
responsible to everyone else and
everyone is giving constant feedback to
everyone else on how to improve with
empathy
and with honesty that is where you can
create an organization or a social
structure and a social hierarchy that
actually allows everyone to win and
allows everyone to succeed and allows
everyone to explore all of the levels of
Maslow's hierarchy right that's how you
become fully human and fully yourself
thank you Matt I promise I will get to
some of the other insurance questions
and none of you selfish for just a
second here and ask a question when you
you said part of the role in a leader is
removing some of those blockers for your
your team and
I'm wondering for some of us here who
maybe are in a role where we've
identified certain blockers for us
how would you recommend you go about
like
sharing that with your leadership to to
kind of get past those roadblocks
whether it's an i or a we right
sometimes there's a blocker for a whole
team and sometimes there's a block of or
an individual right I think what you
need to do is
I I don't know if any of you have taken
any courses in non-violent communication
it's kind of a big thing now we've taken
a lot in non-violent communication
um I don't believe all of it but I think
it is a tool set where you can sort of
mix and match some of the tools that
come out of non-violent communication
one of those things is to listen for
needs and to express needs right so you
start with I'm trying to do this for the
company
I believe that this is going to be very
valuable do you agree right so first
you've got to get buy-in on what you're
trying to do is valuable for the
organization of valuable for the company
okay the second thing is in in order to
do that I have certain needs that are
not being met
okay this is what those needs are it
could be an individual could be a group
of individuals it could be a dynamic it
could be technology that isn't isn't
there it could be budget it could be
whatever right and then you really
Express that as a need not as a
so-and-so is doing something to me in a
mad right that's that's a very sort of a
selfish communication what you want to
do is you want to try to abstract that
as much as you can now you can't always
because sometimes there's just a person
who isn't on board right and and so you
say look I really need this person to be
on board but I don't think this person
is on board and I want to ask you what
we can do together in order to try and
identify that other person's needs and
discover why it is uh that they appear
to be a blocker it may be in my own head
and I'm just you know I I'm just in an
echo chamber but let's have that
conversation and if you don't feel
confident having that conversation
yourself go to someone who you think can
have that conversation and it doesn't
have to be a manager it could be a
colleague who knows that convert that
person really well and can set up that
meeting so that you can have that
meeting and identify what those needs
are there's another book that I would
really strongly recommend and
unfortunately it's escaping me um right
now the guy's name is Chris Voss it's
called Never split the difference I
don't know if any of you have read that
strongly encourage you to read that book
um some of it's throw away right but you
know I follow the Pareto Principle so
there's always 20 percent of you know
absolutely fantastic nuggets in every
book
um
so that book basically teaches you to
get to know
you you talk to an individual and you
have a dialogue with them you have a
dialectic with them until you get to why
they're saying no to whatever thing you
want to get through right because yeses
that aren't really yeses don't matter
you have to get to the no right and so
that I I think making sure that you
understand what the other person's needs
are
um or the organization's needs if that's
a blocker and then making sure that
you're constructing the right
conversation and you're having those
conversations through an expression of
needs on both sides a reciprocal
expression of needs usually that is the
Black Swan that will bust right through
that blocker
amazing thank you so much Matt that's
incredibly helpful
um okay jumping back over to some of the
questions in the chat
um Alan I see you had a question around
some of the regulatory regulatory
requirements do you want to jump in here
yeah sure thanks uh this is really
really interesting today
um Matt kind of following on the on the
the thread that you started with about
you know these opportunities coming from
data to democratize this industry I
wonder if there's a counterpart
regulatory piece that you see are there
regulatory gaps in that being able to be
successful in this industry that that it
describes being you know a monopolistic
cabal are there regulatory things that
you think are really important either
for Consumer Protection or for
um you know pushing back against
um you know anti-competitive kind of
practices that that would make a
difference
yes and this is where
um my opinions are probably the most
provocative
um I believe that by and large
um
insurance is massively over regulated
massively to to the point that it's
actually been regulated in such a way
that it's extremely difficult for new
entrants to get in right
um I think we've democratized some of it
with a lot of the things that um you
know companies like Valen have done and
other companies constructing Consortium
data sets but the regulatory World in
insurance is extremely Antiquated it is
you know it it they're basically
operating on 1970s principle
by and large okay and those principles
were set up by the insurance industry at
that time which was populated by a very
few extremely large carriers
specifically for the purposes of
creating barriers to entry for new
entries okay so I believe all of the
regulations need to be completely
Rewritten and they need to be completely
Rewritten in view of the latest
Technologies
there is something that one has to
understand about insurance and that is
that uh I don't it it is an asymmetric
information game
okay the insurance carrier gets to ask
questions and they have to ask questions
mostly through a third party through the
insurance agent right and so not only do
you have information asymmetry but you
have information Distortion as as well
and so what the insurance companies are
trying to do is put themselves on a
Level Playing Field because the insured
has all of the knowledge about what
their exposures and what the risks are
the insurance agent has probably 20
percent of that information and the
insurance carrier probably has about 10
percent of that information a lot of
what's becoming available now is
actually increasing that ten percent to
maybe 30 35 of the information right
they're still unconscientious
disagreeable uh people out there that
are lying about all of their information
they're a roofer and they're saying that
they're uh you know a computer
programming company uh they're a trucker
and they're saying that they're a retail
shop right
um and that you know that's where where
models are actually quite good at
determining whether someone is you know
actually lying to you or not right and
and identifying and shaving down the
moral hazard now having said that
um there are still ways now
um and will be ways in the future that
insurance companies can take advantage
of information that the insurer doesn't
even know they have and so I think that
information transparency is a huge piece
of the puzzle I think that um if an
insurance company is making a decision
letting the insured know what decision
what information they're using uh in in
order to render that decision is
probably going to be very important in
the future
um but I think that the regulations
around machine learning and filing
models with the Department of Insurance
and the scrutiny that they have to go
through is massively like exponentially
slowing down the Innovation that could
occur in the insurance industry it's
also why most insurance companies that
I've worked with are choosing not to
file their models there are very few
people that are actually filing models
in the commercial insurance space in the
personal Auto space or the personal line
space you have to file all of your
models so the Department of Insurance
gets to look at it they get to
scrutinize it they can say no on just
about anything and they do uh and there
are some states that don't even allow
for trade secret so once you have to
file your model with the Department of
Insurance your competitor can actually
get all of that information and rebuild
your model which I've done several times
so I think there's there needs to be
massive changes uh in regulation around
data science machine learning and
algorithms and how they're used uh in
determining pricing uh and availability
of insurance coverage
um but I think it also needs to be in
light of the fact that insurance
carriers are playing an information
asymmetric game we do not have as much
information as we need in order to
render the best possible coverage and
pricing decision on an individual
business and really that's what we're
trying to do we're essentially buying
used cars and we have to figure out
whether that used car has had something
bad that the you know the
the seller of that used car knows
exactly what's going on with that car we
don't know exactly that car and that's
what I think most insurance carriers are
trying to solve
thanks there's a bunch there that's
that's super interesting and a lot of
perspective especially about asymmetric
information
um that's new for me to think about
appreciate hearing it thank you
absolutely
AJ I see had a question in the chat as
well do you want to jump in here
uh sure yeah I wanted to get your
opinion on see how far is some of these
job functions being automated such as
underwriting or app input
uh because AI is so much Advanced and
it's reading so much data from your
database vast databases so yep uh your
thoughts on that yeah so there's I don't
believe that all risks and now with with
the latest technology
um my opinion is changing
um sort of actively as I start to
understand a little bit more about these
llms
um you know and Transformers and the
like
um
I believe that probably
85 to 90 maybe even 95 of the
underwriting decisions that are
currently being made by human beings in
the world will be eliminated through the
use of machine learning and AI that I
mean that's just a simple fact okay
um it is already the case that uh
machine learning models can make a
significantly better and more consistent
decisions uh than than humans now it is
game theoretic right so what uh what the
models are not quite as good yet at
doing
um and obviously there's ways for to
solve this using models they're not
quite as good at understanding the
market conditions and the changing
market conditions with regard to what
the best price might be right
um insurance carriers have to be able to
understand good risk from Bad risk but
they also have to write policies right
and that means that sometimes you have
to make trade-offs and that's where
human beings come in they're making
those trade-offs they're saying well I
might write this in a slightly higher
loss ratio but if I don't write write
this you know this packet of business
and slightly higher loss ratio I'm not
going to have enough Revenue right so
the gains theoretic piece of the puzzle
sort of uh price optimization which is a
really bad word in um in in insurance
but that's how we think right we're
actually doing price optimization every
single day it's just that we're doing it
through human Underwriters I think where
the world's going to go in insurance is
that a lot of the customer service
Personnel are going to be eliminated
because llms are going to take on that
um you know chat Bots uh and RPA and
automation are going to be able to do
probably 95 to 100 of um policy changes
endorsements
um things like that but on the
underwriting side I think that it will
probably eliminate 85 to 90 percent of
the decisions that doesn't mean that the
underwriters role gets eliminated it
means that the underwriters role changes
significantly it changes to a portfolio
management role it changes to a gap
identification role and it changes to a
role where an underwriter is now the
subject matter expert that works
directly with the data science team in
order to identify and explore the gaps
that may exist in the model Solutions
and helps to fill those with novel data
uh and perspective that sometimes a lot
of the data science teams don't have
because they're not on the front lines
and that's sort of a surrogate is it is
really important in assurance that the
data science team actually has a working
knowledge of the line of business that
they're actually looking at so if you
are building a model for commercial Auto
you have to understand Commercial Auto
you have to understand how it's rated
you have to understand the coverages ETC
I have a lot of PhD data scientists that
I've worked with in the past that felt
like hey I'm a data scientist I don't
need to know the underlying environment
I'm just going to grab the data and I'm
going to build a model I can tell you
that in my experience ninety percent of
the models that are built in that
fashion fail
because they cannot be productionalized
the data scientists didn't find out
whether the information was available at
the time that the decision the decision
needed to be made or the target was not
transformed in a way that was critically
important because the data was centered
censored or there was a treatment effect
that they did not identify until after
they built them up and they have to
rebuild the whole model over again
thank you that there's this is kind of a
follow-up question here about talking
about building this model there was a
anonymous question it was can you walk
through how your team approaches finding
a valuable question exploring that
question building and testing a
predictive model and then deploying that
the kind of the technical aspect of that
I'm going to try and be concise there
I'm not sure how concise I can be
um that's okay so
generally speaking we will
on a regular basis go out to each one of
the department heads and we will ask
them you know what what are your
problems today what is creating too much
friction
um what is something that you think
um could be better decision that's being
partly decision today right and then
we'll get all of that information back
okay
once we construct all of the
quote-unquote potential opportunities
for data science then we start to look
around at the available data sources
that we have and we start to do some
Discovery around whether or not we can
actually solve that particular problem
with data do we have the data available
to be able to solve that problem is that
problem a big enough problem to solve
right so usually once we go to the
department heads we'll then go to the
business or Department analysts within
that particular department and say hey
how big of a problem is this can we
quantify uh the friction can we quantify
how much this is costing us how many
minutes how many hours how many days how
many you know how many
um employee days does this take and what
is theoretically if we were able to
remove that and automate that what would
the savings be right and then of course
there's there's other things and
insurance how much better can we make
around these these decisions whether it
be can I separate good risk from Bad
risk can I identify by the probability
that someone's actually going to pay
their bills can I identify the cost if
they don't pay their bills can I
identify how many times they're not
going to pay their bills and we've got
to do something with that policy whether
it be to cancel it and reinstate it and
all that stuff because that costs
insurance company money
um all of those different things even on
the marketing side right so what is our
um what's our current customer
acquisition cost and where is it
relatively high and is there a way for
us to build a model in order to lower
that right so there's a wide variety of
different things that that you can do
once you once you sit on a problem and
you know that there's enough value there
and you know that you have the data to
be able to solve that problem then it's
a pretty standard process you have to
Wrangle the data you have to normalize
the data you have to work together with
the Department experts in that
department to identify what they think
might be interesting or valuable
covariates right so usually we will do
some unsupervised modeling just to
figure out what the data looks like
right where might there be Blooms of
data that could be interesting and then
we'll do a correlation study which is
with as many covariates that we can
actually put together and then bring
that back to the department and then ask
the subject matter expert what's not in
here that you think should be in here
right and then they'll start to think
about and construct some additional
features then you start the feature
engineering phase right you do that with
the subject matter experts in that
department and you try and get as many
features that you think might be useful
as possible
um and then of course there's some
Target Transformations sometimes are you
going to build a logistic model are you
going to build a linear model are you
going to build something that you're
going to use for triage is it going
going to be sort of a categorical model
where you've got five or six different
you know decisions that need to be made
and you're going to split those up you
kind of figure out what the best sort of
you know opportunity is there
um and then we usually go through sample
and partitioning how are you going to
sample this what's your strategy going
to be
um what is your validation strategy so
are you going to do crossfall validation
what's your holdout going to look like
what your train set going to look like
what your testing is that going to look
like are those stratified correctly uh
is is anything time series based right
because that has a significant impact on
how you're thinking about your sampling
strategy usually in Insurance depending
on data size right and the composition
of the target we use anywhere between
three partitions and 10 partitions right
if it's a more complicated problem and
we've got a lot of data we'll use up to
10 partitions and we'll hold three or
four of them out and then we'll use
incrementally uh four or five or six or
seven of those in order to increase
increments through the overall model
building process will use the first
partition maybe even split that up in in
order to do feature engineering and
basic variable selection and reduction
then we will build our initial model and
then we'll test it on the next partition
and then normally what we do is we'll
build on let's say you have five
different partitions we build on one and
two test on three build on one and three
test on two build on two and three test
on one right and then once you're really
confident that you've got the right
model using that data you add the next
partition now you've got one two and
three built on four four three and two
built on what that you know tested on
one and so on and so forth right and
we're constantly looking coefficients
where they're shifting whether they're
going up and down it's the tree model
we're looking at what the splits look
like uh we're sort of doing hyper
parameter selection usually on those
early partitions until you get to the
final model usually with two or three
validations that's already held out and
in Insurance we're usually using between
5 five and eight crossfold validation at
each one of those stages just to make
sure that we're getting
um there's a lot of volatility because
of the zero point mass in insurance so
you really need to make sure that you've
got enough crossfold validation there
because you can have a very large loss
that makes things look really weird in
any one partition of the data that
you're looking at
hopefully that helps because I could go
on on that for like an hour and a half
no thank you very much we threw a lot at
you with that with that one question
um I think we have time for one more
question
um kalau I see you had asked uh
something a bit earlier about training
do you want to jump in with your
question
yeah sure I'm happy to jump in hi Matt
uh my name is clao I'm a customer
successor up here at posit
um she's actually my customer success
yes for pie Insurance
um and a few others on the call actually
but
um yeah there seems to be so much to
know in this space not just for
insurance but like data science
programming in general
um and as somebody who might be just
starting out in industry or you know
coming out of college
um how would they get a job I guess you
know like what skills or knowledge do
you think they should have or what is
you know what are teams like yours
looking for in new hires
um
yeah I mean so I think a working
knowledge of both Python and I'm going
to say it uh R right R and python a
working knowledge of both of those is
really important the the biggest piece
of the puzzle for me is an understanding
of
um what I would call pragmatic
productionalizable model building right
do not uh narrow your scope uh or your
interest down to research alone you need
to know how to get models into
production so that they can be used by
actors in the real world right if you're
doing descriptive statistics
um that's great I mean and if that's
what you want to do great but you're
going to cut yourself short if you don't
know how to deploy a model you're going
to cut yourself short if you don't know
what the process looked like in order to
deploy a model you don't necessarily
need to know how to do the engineering
right you can get an ml Ops Team for
that but you need to know as a data
scientist how to do things like parity
testing uh predictions between the
production environment and the model
build environment right you need to
understand what that looks like what
that process looks like right and you
need to understand how to actually go
The Last Mile if you will right if
you're just building General linear
models and you're doing that
descriptively and you're saying look I
built a model and it looks great right
the next question that any executive is
going to ask you is okay how do we use
this how are we going to deploy this are
we going to deploy it in SQL are we
going to containerize it are we going to
use Scala are we going to do something
else in order to get that model into you
know pmml whatever the case may be how
do we get that model into production and
how do we know that that production
model is going to score the same way as
it did in the model build environment I
think the other one is having a really
good understanding and an ability to
articulate what the model building
process looks like all the way from
finding the data sources all the way
through to validating that model and
making sure that you don't have an
overfit model and that that model is
really going to perform as you say it's
going to perform in the real world on
data that it hasn't seen before those
are all really really important the last
point that I'll make is it is critically
important for you to show in any
interview or to any
um
business manager that you have a high
level of curiosity in the business that
you're in don't sell yourself short and
just be a data scientist you need to be
a curious data scientist if it's an
insurance you need to want to learn
insurance if it's in Aeronautics you
need to want to learn Aeronautics if
it's in process optimization uh for I
don't know making candy bars you need to
really be curious and interested in in
what the process looks like to make a
candy bar right I think that that's
really really important is that data
scientists can't just be data scientists
they have to be Renaissance people
and constantly curious and autodidactic
that that's the best advice that I can
give
um is don't narrow yourself don't be
um an inch wide and a mile deep
be a mile wide and and more than a few
inches deep
great thanks Matt yep
thank you so much Matt I know we quickly
came to the top of the hour here that I
I really appreciated this conversation
and you jumping on here and joining us
absolutely my pleasure I had a fun time
thank you all for all the great
questions too I'm gonna put Matt's
LinkedIn and the uh chat here if anybody
wants to to connect but also I will
share the recording of course to YouTube
and to the posit data science hangout
site have a great rest of the day
everybody